this video is brought to you by blinkers
now look it's not always easy to find
the time to sit down and read all of the
books that you want to I know there's
some are pretty busy dude myself so I
understand that and I don't read nearly
as much as I used to just because I
don't have as much time as I used to but
good news
I have bling kissed which is this app
you can download and in this app there
are 15 minute summaries of all of the
best non-fiction books indeed there are
3,000 of them you can either read or
listen to them I listen 90% of the time
because I tend to be you know commuting
to work or doing something around the
house and I'll just pop it on and get a
15 minute listen but if you prefer to
read obviously that option is there as
well
there are 12 million active users using
Linkous right now to get the best
insights and need-to-know info from
thousands of books from self-help to
business to health whatever you're into
it's on that they've also got excellent
curated lists where the Blink esteem and
also guests to put together some
specific recommendations like how to
future-proof yourself or just some of
the team over there's favorites and of
course you can download them listen to
them offline indeed I've got fact
fulness which is a great book that I've
actually read and I've got the summary
right here kind of just a bit of a recap
for me so the first hundred people to go
to blink is calm forward slash visual
politic you'll get a week to try it out
you'll also get 25% off if you want the
full membership and again seven day
trial cancel at any time just go to
blinkers comm forward slash visual
politic and let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
now we don't have a Wikipedia page yes
but if we ever had one the truth is that
until recently you could not have
accessed that in Turkey until January
the 15th 2020 even Wikipedia the famous
website that we all use from time to
time to answer questions and that has
practically defines an entire generation
was blocked in Turkey turkey removes ban
on Wikipedia after almost three years
Bloomberg the reason law five six five
one on the regulation of Internet
publications and combating crimes
committed through such publications yes
that's the official name and that's why
it's so long although they could have
summarized it better as the Internet
censorship Act
a law was passed in May 2007 and amended
in February 2014 to establish greater
control over access to online content by
May 2015 just a year later the Turkish
government had already blocked more than
80 thousand websites and by the end of
2018 that figure had risen to more than
two hundred and forty five thousand
yeah that's right a quarter of a million
pages blocked by the government of a
country that is still currently looking
to join the European Union well that's
probably not gonna happen anymore now
I'm sure many of you are wondering why
is turkey is so committed to controlling
information what are the reasons for
this regression well as you can imagine
our friend o Diwan has got a lot to do
with it you want to know more well let's
get into it
[Music]
the return of the dictatorship
if there is one political leader in the
Western world who is in recent years
changed his opinions ideas and messages
more than a weathervane that would be
our one to give you an idea the Turkish
president has spent a few years saying
things like this you want to prove that
a Muslim country can be democratic
transparent and compatible with the
modern world rage of tie up everyone and
they're not so much later he comes out
with something like this democracy is
like a train when you reach your
destination you get off rage if tie it
bare to one surprised well don't think
for a moment that erawan is one of those
guys who is just full of empty threats
not at all we are looking at a
politician who sometimes does what he
says most of the time when censorship
and democratic regression are involved
take a look at this turkey sentences 24
journalists to prison claiming terrorism
tithes most of the journalists worked
for news organizations that are
considered friendly to Fethullah Gulen a
cleric living in seclusion in a small
town in Pennsylvania
the Turkish government claims that mr.
Gulen leads a shadowy violent movement
aiming to overthrow President raped I
appeared on the New York Times this kind
of thing is happening more and more
frequently in Turkey and only confirms
something that virtually no one could
argue with the country which was once
the most advanced and free democracy in
the Islamic world is today on its way to
becoming yet another autocracy or at
least to becoming one of those new
political hybrids that have become so
fashionable throughout the world where
authoritarianism weighs in far more than
Democratic fundamentals and obviously in
order to consolidate such an autocracy
in the 21st century the first thing you
have to do is control the internet
that's in the very first chapter of the
manual on how to be a dictator now what
exactly is going on in Turkey is the
situation really so serious is there any
hope of preventing the restrictions on
Internet freedom from progressing even
further well let's find out
how did it all begin
imagine got one day you wake up in the
morning and learn that your government
as hard hackers to spy on the sites that
you visit on the Internet well that is
pretty much what happens to regular
Turkish citizens in 2015 the government
hired a hacking company do control the
data traffic of Turkish Internet users
to more than three years but let's be
fair because this is hardly surprising
other one had some very very clear plans
in mind practically since day one of
taking over the reins of Turkey back in
2003 we can start right here with
YouTube in 2008 turkey blocked this very
platform because of videos insulting
Mustafa Kemal atatürk the founder of
modern Turkey
the blockade lasted no less than two
years so at what point did all of this
slip out of the hands of the Turkish
presidents ready news coming out of
Turkey right now Taksim Square
I'm Lisa just moved in once again firing
teargas
well as I'm sure many of you will
remember between May and August 2013
there were massive protests against the
Turkish government that took place in
Istanbul's Taksim Square these protests
initially arose with the aim of
preventing the destruction of geezy park
to build a shopping center hence the
protests were known as the Kesey park
protests but the authority's response
was so heavy-handed that what began as a
protest to preserve the park quickly
ended up becoming a whole movement
against government authoritarianism give
you an idea at least 22 people died more
than eight thousand were injured and a
further 4900 were arrested in more than
90 cities throughout the country this is
how the first major social response
against the authoritarian Iran took
place but what does all of this have to
do with cyber authoritarianism well
during the protests the Turkish
government closely monitored Twitter's
trending topics and had no hesitation in
arresting users of the popular social
network who posted anything unfavorable
about the government the government also
turned off 3G antennas to prevent
protesters from coordinating with each
other
and you know what basically this was the
turning point the moment went the
Turkish leader started to take pleasure
in controlling the internet so just a
short time later in 2014 I won to
advantage of the amendments in law five
six five one which we mentioned at the
very beginning of this video so that
just one month after its entry into the
law Twitter was blocked Twitter website
blocked in Turkey BBC as you can see
it's all very very democratic and of
course you know how these things go when
a ruler begins to control freedom of
expression sense of the internet and
amends the law so he can do what he
wants at will it doesn't happen just
once twice or three times but it becomes
systemic
for example in February 2020 the Turkish
government again blocked access to
social media following a Turkish
airstrike in Syria Turkey blocked social
media access for 16 hours after Syria
airstrike euronews these practices are
becoming more common in Turkish citizens
no longer or even sure when they'll have
access to their social networks and when
they won't while it's true these things
do happen in countries like Saudi Arabia
or Iran they are not typical in a
country that is supposed to be
democratic in fact things went so far
that Freedom House classified Turkey
with a score of 37 out of 100 in
networked freedom and although it's had
worse records for a few years keep in
mind the countries with scores or less
than 40 points are considered to have a
blocked Internet network
[Music]
and the question is can we really talk
about a democracy in a country where the
internet is censored
[Music]
you should realize that turkey gets this
gone not because of online connectivity
which by the way would easily score
highly and that because of content
control and for constantly violating
users rights privacy and the freedom to
access content critical of the
government and of the state
[Music]
but what power does the infamous law 565
1 grants to control the network what's
going on in practice in everyday life
[Music]
censorship in its day to day effect if
anything has forever changed the way
Turkish people surf the Internet it has
been law 5 6 5 1 this law in practice
serves to regulate the Turkish state
censorship of citizens not only on the
internet but it also controls content on
streaming platforms such as Netflix yeah
that's right this law states that all
content that streams over the Internet
such as online radio and television must
be licensed by RT UK the radio and
television Supreme Council of Turkey in
fact major local streaming platforms
such as blue TV or foreign ones such as
Netflix had to apply for new licenses in
order to continue operating in the
country in this way the state has been
able to screen the platforms and content
that might be served and has subjected
its contents to moral standards look
what are the paragraphs of the law
itself the aim of this regulation is to
establish the methods and principles to
regulate the presentation and provision
of radio television and on-demand
broadcast services the handling of
broadcast licenses to media service
providers the granting of broadcasting
authorities to platform administrators
and the supervision of the broadcasts in
question law five six five one well in
the case of Netflix a platform that has
about one and a half million users in
Turkey in order to continue providing
service to them the US company had to
establish a local entity to operate and
give 0.5% of the revenue from Turkish
users to the government
but that's not even the worst part even
more controversial is that the content
is overseen by a government dependent
body the hire Council of radio and
television which among other things is
responsible for protecting public morals
whatever their names anyway that's a
snapshot of how things are in Turkey the
hope that a democratic government would
end up leading the Middle East has faded
at roughly the same rates as Iran has
emerged as an almighty warlord today it
is clear that Turkish internet users
have an arduous battle for freedom ahead
of them so I really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
please do check out our friends at their
you consider media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video if you want to learn more about
politics and world affairs and here's
some more of my lovely voice come check
out the reconsidered podcast where we
don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider at WWE consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast